- Good morning, believe nation.
Today's message is live in the moment.
Over to you, Misty Copeland.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I think that when I was
younger, I was just, you know,
you get so like, antsy, and
you just want the good things
to come, and it's hard to
enjoy the process, and I think
that's something that I really
understand and appreciate now.
I mean, my life is so
chaotic with just being busy
all the time, that I
literally just take everything
one step at a time.
Like, even when I'm on the stage,
and I'm like, I can't
think about third act,
I'm in second act now and
I'm going to think about
the pique arabesque I'm about to do,
not about the, you know, the,
the pirouettes I'm going
to do in two seconds.
So it's literally just
like, taking everything,
you know, just pacing yourself
in one thing at a time.
- If you can't learn to
appreciate the moment,
you'll never be happy.
I think one of the things
that we, as entrepreneurs,
are great at, is being
frustrated with the status quo,
is wanting more, it's
wanting to change something,
wanting to change the
way an industry is done,
because we're so angry and frustrated
with how it's currently being done.
And that's great, and that's a strength,
and that's a tool, and
we should lean in on it.
At the same time though,
I want you to be grateful
for what you do have,
to recognize the abundance
of opportunities and wealth
that you have already living.
The fact that you are living,
and watching this video,
and have access to YouTube, puts you ahead
of, still, most of the world.
And, recognizing that, and
being so grateful that if,
even if you never accomplish
any more of your goals,
that you have an amazing life.
I think it's helpful.
Now, I don't think it's,
only focus on how great
everything is, 'cause then,
you don't do anything else.
Right, you don't want to change things.
That little bit of frustration is good,
but I think you need both;
I think too many people
don't lean too hard, on the
negative, on the frustration,
on the way things are currently done, and
if that's all you are chasing,
then you'll never be happy.
There's a great story from
Thich Nhat Hanh, where
he's talking about washing
the dishes to wash the dishes.
He's doing this retreat with his students,
and at the end of every
night, they would go over
to his place, and he
would make them dinner,
and then he would wash the plates.
And, one of the guys
who came to his session
said, hey, let me wash the plates for you.
You did a lot of work, you helped us out,
you fed us, how about I
wash the plates for you.
And he told them that, if
you're going to wash the plates,
then you need to wash the plates.
You wash the plates to wash the plates,
and what that means is, so many times,
when people are washing the
plates, what are you doing?
You're thinking of what's next,
and you're not actually
focused on washing the plates.
You're thinking about the
conversations you're going to have
after you finish washing the dishes.
And then, when you're having
the conversations after,
you're thinking about
what you're going to do
later on that night.
And when you're actually
doing that thing, later on
that night, you're thinking about
what's going to happen tomorrow.
We're so focused on always
thinking about what's next,
that we don't take the time to enjoy
what's happening right now.
I'm enjoying making this
video for you right now.
I'm entirely focused on
just making this video.
I'm not thinking about the next
video that I'm going to do.
I'm not thinking about how
I'm going to spend my evening.
I'm here, trying to be
with you, in this moment.
And the more time you can
spend being in the moment,
it helps you be a happier
and healthier entrepreneur.
I think, too often, we're
focused just on thinking about
what's happening next, and we
don't actually get to spend
time enjoying our family,
enjoying our customers,
enjoying the work and the
process that we're doing.
So if you can take all of
that, and learn to be present,
and yes, focus on the frustrations,
so that it helps you become
a better entrepreneur,
but at the same time, be grateful,
and mindful in the moment, for
everything that you do have.
I think it'll make you happier, healthier,
and a more successful entrepreneur.
So the question of the day
today, is, I'm curious,
what do you do to be
present, in the moment?
Curious to find out, leave
it in the comments below.
I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Peter.
Peter, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really means a lot to me, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning,
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- A Head Full of Dreams,
the tour is going on now,
you just got off the South American line.
I mean, the crowds, the show,
does it ever, how do you keep it fresh?
Because, it's not your first rodeo,
it's your thousands,
ten-thousands, I mean,
you've been doing it.
- Well, here's how we keep it fresh:
Bruce Springsteen,
apparently, I don't know
if he really does or not, used to say
to the rest of the E Street Band,
this could be someone's first show
and it could be someone's last show.
So, let's treat it like that.
So, I have that inspiration, and then
some other things in my
life, that just make me,
every time, before we go on
stage, I really think about
like, who's showed up, how
much they've been through
to get there, and,
also for us, at the moment,
we're just so into it.
We took a break from
touring, on the last album
we did, called Ghost
Stories, so we're so excited
to be there, and we know
that nothing lasts forever,
so I think that we're just really,
more than ever, living in the moment,
and trying to appreciate the fact that,
for some people, it's their first show,
and some people, you know, you know.
- And, that has to be a perspective that,
that's not immediate, right?
You learn that perspective.
- You have to work
to that perspective.
- Yeah.
- We definitely went through
a period, about 10 years ago,
of feeling like, what are we doing?
You know, questioning
everything, and not really
able to take in the joy of it.
- [Interviewer] That must have been hard.
- I mean, everything's in
perspective, but for us,
as a band, it was a bit hard,
like, what are we, you know.
But, slowly, just, you keep
going, and you find great people
who come in and help you
out, and teach you things.
And I think, the more that you let in,
it's very easy right
now, with social media,
to let in anything negative, you know.
Whatever you do, someone is
going to slag it off, online.
- Well, you're not on social media at all.
- Personally, we are as a band.
I don't really personally do it.
I'm not that good at selfies.
(laughing)
- That's the honest answer.
- That's the reason.
- Yeah.
So I made a decision that, well, you know,
it's easy to take in the bad stuff,
so I'm going to really
take in the good stuff, and
appreciate, these people have shown up,
and they want to sing
our songs together, and
that's great, I'm into it.
- It can't ever get old.
- So it's very fresh.
It never gets old.
That's the thing, it never gets old.
- You're not meant to
put a goal on your life.
You're not meant to say, once
I get there, I'll have it all.
I think that that's the biggest
lesson I've needed to learn,
is how to be present, in that moment,
and to know that I'm always
going to strive for something.
I think everybody who's watched my story,
they've seen that not
everything has kind of been
handed to me, and I've been
honest about everything.
Some of the things that
haven't been me, in the past,
and other things, I've
been so passionate about,
and so spot-on with.
So, if anything, that's
what Revival represents.
It's that, I feel the most
confident I've ever felt,
and it goes like that.
(laughing)
It's like, it's constantly changing,
and I don't know, I think that's just,
that's what I want it to feel like.
- Your background is
fairly well documented,
the things you went through,
which have shaped you.
How much of that is really behind you?
How much do those ghosts still haunt you?
The involvement in, you know,
issues that got you in prison,
and tortured, and, you know,
the drug use, and so on.
- I am myself, and my circumstance.
I think that, like a Spanish philosopher,
used to say, so, who am I?
I'm a sum of all the experience
that I lived, in my life.
That said, of course, I don't look back,
because if I look back,
I may become a start of salt.
So I try to live my life here,
but it is the sum of difficult moments,
good moments, experiences
that I had in my life,
that brought me here,
in front of this camera,
talking to you.
You don't live your life,
in this capitalistic sense,
that to accumulate knowledge,
as you accumulate money.
No, no, no, no, no.
Life is about the present moment.
And, you're here, you're here now,
and then you have an
idea, or have something,
but that may be a root in your past,
but you don't know, so what I try to do,
is to live my life as full,
as intensely, as I can.